قال الرئيس الاستخبارات في وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ان القتال بين الجيشين الروسي
والاكراني في ديسمبر وصل ما سماه الطريقه
المسدود واوضح ان كلا الجانبين يعاني نقصا
في العدد والعتاد مشيرا الى ان الجيش
الاوكراني لا يقوى على هزيمه روسيا بشكل
كامل وعلى كل الجبهات حاليا وكشف ان الامر
يعتمد على المساعدات العسكريه التي
ستتلقاها اوكرانيا من حلفائها
وينضم الينا من كيف مراسلنا تامر رسمادي
اذا تامر اخر التطورات من حيث تقف فيك
تفضل
نعم تطورات سياسيه وميدانيه في الحقيقه
ليلى العاصمه كانت تعرضت فجر هذا اليوم
لهجوم جديد من قبل القوات الروسيه وفقا
للاداره العسكريه والمدنيه هنا في العاصمه
تحدثت عن هجوم بسيارات ايرانيه من نوع
شاهد وقالت بان هذه المسيرات كانت تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه التي تضررت الى حد كبير
يوم امس بالقصف الصاروخي الواسع الذي شمل
كيف وعديد المقاطعه الجنوبيه والغربيه
والشماليه ايضا
السلطات الاوكرانيه قالت بان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت تسعه طائرات هنا في كياب
وتحدثت عن اسقاط طائرات اخرى في الجنوب
والشمال تحديدا في مقاطعه اسقطت السلطات
هنالك ثلاثه طائرات همم من نوع شاهد ايضا
وفقا لما وردته من بيانات وقالت بان تلك
الطائرات بعضها كان يستهدف البنيه وتحدثت
عن مقتل همم مدني لكن في الحقيقه تطورات
الميدانيه ضلت متسارعه في خيرسون جنوب
البلاد خلال الساعات الاخيره تحدثت
القياده العسكريه هناك بان اكثر من 80
هجوما شنته القوات الروسيه على على
العديد من القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خط
التماس تحديدا عند ضفتي نهر دنيبر وتحدثت
ايضا عن تطورات متلاحقه في زبروجيا تحديدا
القصف الاوكرانيا المكثف بالمدفعيه
الثقيله كما تقول السلطات هناك على مواقع
تمركز القوات الروسيه في ريف زباروجا
الجنوبي تركماك ميليتوبيل وتحدثت عن اكثر
من 50 قتيلا في صفوف الجنود الروس لكن
التطورات السياسيه ليلى متطوره جدا تحديدا
فيما اورده مستشار نهايه الليله اذا سمحتي
فيما اورده مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الذي
قال بان هنالك مبادئ واضحه في اي مفاوضات
مستقبليه لن يتم التنازل عن همم اي من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الدونباس وشبه جزيره
القرم واكد بان هنالك توافق اوكراني
امريكي على ذلك ووسط كل هذه التطورات
الميدانيه والسياسيه تامر فقط لفتني ان
الحياه من خلف كتاب عاديه كانها الكل يعني
يتمشمون في اجواء احتفالات واعياد صف لنا
فقط بشكل سريع لو سمحت
الاجواء يعني المواطن العادي كيف يشعر فيك
كيف
نعم كيف منذ يومين وهي تتعرض كما قلت في
البدايه ليله لها جمات لكن هذه الى هجمات
وهي من فتره لاخرى ايضا تتعرض لقصف من قبل
القوات الروسيه كما تورد وتؤكد السلطات
الاوكرانيه هنا لكن كل ذلك لا يؤثر على
حركه الناس في الشارع الناس منذ فتره
طويله عادوا الى اعمالهم الى اشغالهم
وتحديدا عشريه راس السنه الاعلام
الاوكرانيه ترتفع في الشوارع وايضا
الاغاني الوطنيه اينما تجاولت في الشوارع
الرئيسيه هنا في كيا في الميادين الرئيسيه
ستستمعين الى صوت الاغاني الوطنيه تهدر في
كل مكان وهنالك شعور حاولت السلطات
الاوكرانيه بدءا من الرئيس الاوكراني
مرورا بالعديد من المستشارين السياسيه
الوصولا الى القياده العسكريه شعور
يحاولون ايصاله وبثته في اوساط الناس
باننا نقترب من النصر وهذا ما كانت تتحدث
عنه السلطات الاخرانيه طيله الفتره
الماضيه بان العام المقبل لم يبق عنه شيء
هو عام سوف تحقق في كثير من الانجازات لا
سيما في ظل التقدم الذي جرى خلال الفتره
الماضيه على اكثر من محور وفي ظل الحديث
عن مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه قد تصل تباع
سبحان الله
الانسان يعني قدر على التعايش مع اقصى
الظروف حتى في الظروف الحرب الحاليه شكرا
جزيلا لك تامر الصمادي